can you believe that as a 28-year-old
unmarried woman I'm literally too old to
be called a spinster the correct term
for someone in my apparently geriatric
state is a thorn back Society is so
obsessed with marriage that not only do
we Define ourselves by our relationship
status which was like 42% of my
motivation for getting my doctorate in
the first place but we've created a
social ideal wherein the only way to
truly live happily ever after is to fall
in love and stay that way yet nearly
half of marriages in the us and in
divorce because love doesn't always last
forever I should know I was engaged and
head over heels before a bad breakup
last year everyone in my life expected
me to be a devastated wreck for weeks
and I was at first but it didn't take
long for me to see the Silver Linings at
the time I was comforted by a story
about a fellow thornback the Hawaiian
volcano goddess P Honua Maya P to her
friends who found love but gained so
much more when it was lost it's an
interesting story even if you haven't
recently had your heartbroken full of
magical fight scenes canoes and even
[Music]
murder maybe you've heard of P she's a
major figure in Hawaiian mythology and
pop culture allegedly the inspiration
for tafiti in Disney's Moana because
tafiti is not a real goddess in
Polynesian folklore but most people
don't know that P was briefly entangled
with a shape-shifting demigod named
kamap puaa some would call him P's
husband but that's not really an
appropriate label because Hawaiians
didn't have a western concept of
marriage there were unions that could be
blessed by gods and the chief but they
weren't legally binding and divorce just
wasn't a thing they don't really teach
us this in history class but Hawaii was
a Sovereign Nation with its own language
and culture before colonization in the
1700s they were an oral Society passing
their knowledge about how the world
Works onto the Next Generation through
stories or moo for example the moo use
Comm puaa and P's relationship as an
explanation for Hawaii's Rich ecological
tapestry in myth p is depicted as the
Divine embodiment of lava who was
equally likely to Aid or un alive you a
true chaotic neutral on the alignment
chart Hawaiians revered p as the creator
of their Islands just as much as they
feared for the destruction she caused
there are many versions of P's story but
in most of them P was born to Divine
parents in the legendary ancestral
Homeland Kahiki through some linguistic
magic those K's become T's and you see
the real history of Polynesian migration
from Tahiti reflected in Hawaiian moo py
had many siblings with their own
abilities to control the sea or clouds
but she took after her uncle Lono makua
who taught her how to control fire even
as a child her immense power or Mana was
obvious and not that it matters but she
was also said to be quite beautiful one
of P's sisters a sea goddess named
namaka okah grew jealous and chased P
from Kahiki in some versions namaka
resents P's strength and in others P has
an affair with nam's
partner why are you chasing me because
you stole my husband it wasn't me
because you set my house on fire it
wasn't me because you're just too strong
I swear on my life that it wasn't
me
girl okay maybe it was me P fled from
her sister with a few of her siblings
trying to find a new home for them and
her fire several times she dug into the
Earth to build a fire pit only to be
flooded by her sister's salty Revenge
Pelle moved Southeast from Kawaii to
aahu and then to Maui where she
ultimately succumbed to her sister's
attack but Mana as strong as P's can't
be stopped by death free from her more
human form P's fiery Spirit traveled to
the big island of Hawaii To Make Her
Last Stand pelle's lava made land that
traced the path of her voyage and now
she lives with her family in Hawaii's
active kilaa volcano kamap pua's Origins
are just as Rocky figuratively speaking
since geology is in his domain he is
another major figure in Hawaiian
folklore known as the hog God of aahu
and associated with fertility and
agriculture again there are many
versions of the story but by most
accounts kamap puaa was born on a wahoo
to his mother Hina the goddess of the
moon Hina was married to Chief Olana but
was crushing hard on his more attractive
younger brother born into this Jon Snow
situation through no fault of his own
these daddy issues LED kamap puaa down a
violent path like the betterk known
demigod Maui kamap puaa was a kopua a
magical shape shifter in his human form
kamap puaa was handsome and Charming
I'll be it quick to anger but he could
shift at will into a hog as well as
certain fish and plants heartbroken over
his father's disgust kamap Pua started
raiding oana's lands in some stories he
makes his human form more closely
resemble his hog shape by cutting his
hair short and spiky tattooing his body
with dark ink and wearing a jacket with
spines down the back Kap puaa was
apprehended and released multiple times
until he was blinded Enough by his Fury
to kill the chief and much like P flee
to the next island in the chain he
hopped from one Island to another
picking fights on each one and earning
himself a nasty reputation as a brute
finally he came to Hawaii where he saw p
and was instantly enamored of her beauty
both p and kamap puaa had strong
personalities he was unapologetically
crass and violent and she had little
patience to suffer fools especially one
who was supposed to be her equal partner
they were simultaneously too similar and
too different clashing in ways that make
great entertainment but a terrible
relationship kamap Pua stood at top the
volcano crater where he first saw p and
tried to woo her with songs and dancing
but p foreshadowing the rise of Shania
Twain was not much impressed you're a
pig and the son of a pig she derided him
which sent Kama Pua into a fit of rage p
is lovely p is so sweet P you would love
me if only we could
meet ew that's gross you're a pig and
you're the son of a pig yeah well your
mother was a hamster and your father
smells like elderberries isn't that for
Monty Python and the Holy Grail we don't
even have elderberries in Hawaii and
were about a thousand years too early
for that reference I love that you know
that the two hurled insults at each
other until P Voli with smoke and Flame
instead of words kamapuaa easily
countered her attack perhaps with
weather powers of his own or help from
his water God family members P shook the
Earth and sent streams of lava to burn
kapua who turned into grass to divert
her flows and answered with floods of
his own nearly drowning p and her family
battle raged until the two realized
neither one had the upper hand and their
passion transformed into something more
intimate for the first time in his life
kamapuaa felt loved and happy but it
wasn't P's responsibility to keep him
that way P realized that their
relationship was toxic though not in the
comforting way that her volcano fumes
were and that it was keeping her from
realizing her true potential as Hawaii's
eminent volcano goddess she broke up
with kamap puua and the two agreed to
split the big island in half so they
wouldn't have to interact again I adore
this Trope in fiction and myth P stuck
to the western side where her volcanoes
could generate new Earth and fertilize
the existing land kamap Pua took the
Eastern side where his warm brains could
nourish crops this ju deposition in
climate makes the Big Island one of the
most ecologically diverse places on the
planet I think the best way to describe
the love these two shared is fierce but
even the fiercest affection can crumble
in the face of incompatibility for p and
kamap puaa their relationships Achilles
heal was anger for me and my ex it was
contrasting views on family and for
millions of people who break up or get
divorced each year the final straw could
be adultery Financial stress or a
thousand other issues traditionalists
love to talk about the moral decline of
our society by pointing to marriage
divorce and birth rates but I think
they're missing the bigger picture here
yes marriage rates are dropping but so
are divorce rates younger Generations
are waiting longer to get married making
them more mature and less likely to fall
into the relationship pitfalls their
parents did and the older Generations
who are experiencing slightly higher
divorce rates mostly initiated by women
by the way are ending incompatible
relationships that likely shouldn't have
been legally Bound in the first place
and if our society didn't pressure
people to get married so young for so
long maybe they wouldn't have is it a
coincidence that Hawaii a culture that
historically didn't have the concept of
marriage has the lowest divorce rate in
the US I don't think so these divorce
are learning a powerful lesson breakups
are good actually if a relationship
isn't working it's better to end it and
be grateful for the benefits after P
left him kapua fled to a distant Island
and married a chieus supposedly getting
his own happily ever after P got to
realize her dream of Basking in her own
glory and living with her fire and
family and when my engagement ended I
was able to focus on my friendships and
eat Nutella again I'm glad mythology is
full of love stories and tragedies alike
but I wish there were more stories like
this one where losing love wasn't seen
as tragic so at the next all Millennial
meeting when we decide which industry
we're going to ruin I'm doubling down on
marriage not because I don't believe in
love I do but because all of Polynesia
would have been worse off if p and kamap
puaa had actually been married you can
choose to ignore this mythical precedent
if you wish but I have learned my lesson
I still want to fall in love and have a
big party though it's time for another
fantasy p Pantheon pick and it is my
turn to choose a new pick are you ready
Dr Z yes I'm excited okay my pick from
the Hawaiian Pantheon is laa oh have you
heard of her is she the one that's most
associated with hoola yes y she's the
goddess of the hoola and so she's a
goddess of dance which I think we will
absolutely want in our Utopia of course
but she's also a goddess of forest
growth and love and I think that all of
that energy is something we want in our
perfect world those are three things I
really love so I appreciate that
pick